trauma is very delicate and we all have
it you rip off the band-aid too fast
you'll get blown out
it'll be too too scary at once we all
have the capacity to be of service to
others but the first thing we have to
put first is a service to ourselves i
write my books for myself first i do
this work for myself first
believe nation i am super happy to have
the one and only gabby bernstein author
of the new book that is now a new york
times best-selling book congratulations
happy days
welcome aboard
thank you my love thank you nice to be
with you
so listen in the spirit of uh
vulnerability and authenticity
i always get uncomfortable before doing
interviews
and even though we've had like some of
the biggest names on the channel every
time before coming on maybe it's because
i've been
shy introverted or afraid of
disappointing people before doing an
interview there's always this like
discomfort inside me to get ready and
then going through your book
on page 42 you said something that kind
of stopped me in my track so you said
the feelings that make us most
uncomfortable
reveal to us what we need to heal
yeah and in reading that i had this i
had to close the book i looked at the
cover there's gary bernstein looking
back at me kind of giving me a big hug
first of all
yeah but then also it made me think huh
i wonder what
big t or little t you know trauma i've
got maybe it's my what protectors do i
have and maybe we'll get into some of
this language but how do you guide
people from
they're uncomfortable with something
how do you guide them to figuring out
what the trauma was that is causing it
that they need to heal from well first
of all i want to just acknowledge how
brave you are to even go there and to
recognize oh my discomfort in this
moment may be revealing something to me
that's that's epic that's amazing that's
that's actually the first step to your
question which is how do we begin to
look at what we might be running from
and the first step is just to witness
that there's something to look at
to give voice to the discomfort
to notice the patterns that are
destructive in our life
to be in the non-judgmental witness of
what's coming up for us
when we have the bravery to just start
to step back and look
and start to take an inventory of those
triggers and the ways that we get
activated and how we feel
when we get activated and how we react
when we get activated
that is the absolute
first and bravest step
it's the bravery to wonder
what might be underneath there
literally what you just did
that's step one
and and all throughout the book i give
these practices for how you can slowly
and
safely titrate into those
subconscious unresolved wounds that we
all have impermissible shame
impermissible rage and permissible
experiences that we never want to
uncover from our history all of us
whether it's big t trauma or small t
trauma
big t being
having lived through a a war or having
lived through a catastrophic event
or being abused
or sexual assault small t trauma being
told you were stupid when you were in
sixth grade or a family member
telling you that you're not good enough
or not feeling supported or seen by your
parents so we all have trauma it's just
how do we show up for it and so that
first step is to be the witness and then
throughout the book i give more and more
guidance on how to slowly and safely
go into it and come out and go into it
and come out because it's not the kind
of thing evan that you want to just rip
the band-aid off too quickly that
wouldn't be safe
what i love about it is it it feels like
it's not just
examining your life in your trauma in a
non-judgmental way
which almost kind of feels like step one
but but you take it a step further to
to almost thank them like to acknowledge
the protector and say hey that that
actually served me
yeah to say there was a positive which
is just feels very different and very
weird compared to what most people
suggest it's like yeah i have to go
through the book again
more slowly like that's right i mean
this is the kind of book this is a kind
of book you should go back to multiple
times but here's here's the thing i
would say so we all have these ways of
protecting ourselves from those
impermissible feelings and in my
language trained in internal family
systems therapy it is known as protector
parts and so our protectors are
the controller or
the uh anxiety in your case the anxiety
of getting on the call with me is like
another protector because it's saying
i'm going to be anxious so that i don't
have to face what's underneath the
anxiety
the ways that we react and respond to
things with with uh picking up a drink
or a drug or uh trying to manage every
corner of our life or workaholism or
or even just numbing out these are
protectors they're parts of us that have
been perfectly placed right here right
now right in this moment
from a historical experience
and they're there from childhood to the
present
creating a world where we can seemingly
feel safe but we don't
it's a it's a protection from that
impermissible feeling that's beneath it
and so where our work is to start to in
this book begin to become aware and
available to those protector parts
and to your point to speak to them and
to notice them and what would how
different would we be if we looked at
our our addiction or our controlling
mechanisms or our anxiety and said
i have so much compassion towards you
and i'm curious about what might be
underneath all that
and i just want to be a calm presence
for you speaking to those parts of
ourselves as if they were other
identities
and just being in that courage to just
have that connection
how different would we be rather than
just being in the reaction all the time
all the time all the time what if we
started to create a relationship with
those reactive parts of us
it's just yeah i'm having goosebumps as
you're talking it's a totally different
perspective and way of looking at it i
think we look back on our lives at the
moment and say well i should have done
better and i should have known more and
we beat ourselves up and and then some
will recommend okay just non-judgmental
just look back but you're actually
basically looking at it as a positive
say hey thank you for protecting me i
needed to do that to to save myself
right
that's another layer you know i've i've
talked in this book very openly about
my recovery from cocaine addiction and
my recovery from remembering childhood
trauma and living through postpartum
depression and suicidal ideation at that
time and i can look back at all of those
parts
the part of me that was the cocaine
addict and the part of me that spun out
out of control right before i remembered
the trauma and the part of me that was
an extreme anxiety during my postpartum
period and say thank you to all of those
parts because they were an up leveling
they were an opportunity for me to look
closer
and they also had an important role
of keeping me safe from experiencing
impermissible feelings too quickly to
fast
and too much at once
so really seeing and honoring and
respecting all of the ways that we've
been no matter how
how shameful they may feel
yeah let me ask you another
uncomfortable question um
so i had a dream about you two nights
ago
about not even laughing because i can't
tell you how many dms i get from people
being like i dreamt about you and that's
what happens when you go to bed with
millions of people at once literally
like my face is in in their nightstand
or maybe in bed with them when you put
your book on their shelf
and they just start dreaming about you
yeah so you had a dream about me yes
let's go on i mean i've probably done
that many times for people who i'm going
to interview but i've never told them
that in an interview
that you know i dreamt about you two
nights ago
uh and so here was a dream so we're
we're just about to go live on this on
this show
and you you politely ask me
not to call you gabby bernstein it's
like please don't call me gabby
bernstein can you call me
and and i forget the name that you
wanted me to call you
um and it that that's kind of been
driving me nuts over the past 24 hours
uh and so i guess where that lease is
the actual name yes it was a specific
name like you said don't come please
don't call me gabby bernstein on your
show call me this
and i just forget what the this was wow
i think i was just so stressed out about
like not don't call her gabby bernie
that i forgot what the name was that i
was supposed to that you asked me to
call you
um and it was it was very polite it
wasn't like anger or hate just like hey
would you mind calling me this instead
um so i guess maybe question from my
dream which i've never asked somebody uh
have you ever used a stage name or a pen
name or an alter ego to create content
or thought about it
what an interesting question well my
name actually did come up in
conversation this morning cause i'm
working with the branding agency who's
redesigning my website and i've never
done any proper branding exercises i've
just been full speed ahead so my brand
is really all over the place
and so he decided that don't call me
gabby bernstein call me gabby
is what we said today huh
interesting so
that's
not necessarily the name i shared with
you but it is actually a conversation i
had this morning
and so i think that
have i ever used a pen name no i've
always been myself i've always been
myself i think that's actually part of
why i do what i do and what i do
why i why what i do works is that i tell
the truth about myself
and in the recounting of my truth i give
people permission to recognize their own
cool i love it there you go evan's dream
that's the answer
i love it um let's talk about your
therapist for a second i mean you're pro
therapy you've helped reduce the stigma
around therapy you've helped normalize
therapy that you don't have to go
through whatever you're struggling with
alone like don't suffer in silence you
thank your therapist you know in the
acknowledgments of your book which uh
nobody does
and if they do it's kind of as a joke
but actually i think two of my
therapists i actually almost dedicated
this book to my therapist but it ended
up my husband deserves the dedication
but i almost dedicated it to her yeah
well and you've talked about how therapy
has like literally saved your life
um
so question when your therapist said who
would play you in a movie
what did you say and why
well i actually joked with her evan i
was like who's gonna play you to her
because like she's such a big role in
this in this storyline that i believe
will probably be a movie i think it's it
could absolutely could be a film
uh who would play me though that's a
good question um let me think it has to
be somebody that can play young and 40
you know because it's like there's a
sort of like decades of storyline
and it's nice if it's the same person
all the way through
there has to be somebody that
really gets it gets this this this
content
i'm gonna i'm gonna sit with it for a
moment and i'm gonna
i'm gonna let you know i'm gonna think
about it all right cool i'm gonna see
what comes yeah well how about this
along similar lines who
who is a hero for you
that are alive that you look up to and
say
she or he is a
just giant inspiration or role model for
me
hmm
uh great giant inspiration for me is my
late publisher and friend louise hay
lulu as we call her at hay house
and i was actually just talking about
louise yesterday because we were talking
about boundaries somehow and
jessica who's my ceo used to work for
hay house and so she worked very closely
with louise and she would always be at
the book signing lines
and
one of the things that would happen is
people would often come to her because
she's so so so soothing and they would
say they would be on this line of
thousands of people and they'd be like
louise just tell me how i can save my
life with this issue and did it and they
would just throw it all on her and she
would look at them with so much love and
compassion and say i'm going to lovingly
and compassionately
say no
and i think that louise to me is a
beautiful
mentor even in the spiritual realm
and comes through in the channeling of
these books
and i think that that boundary is such a
valuable message for
anyone now who's putting out
supportive content in the world
because
you might feel a lot of energy back at
you and you have to create the space to
protect your own energy while being in
the service of others
and there's many other reasons why
louise was such a profound inspiration
for me but that just happened yesterday
i love louise
from the first time i i saw one of her
videos was wow this woman is amazing
we've done a couple tribute videos to
her on on the channel and
i remember thinking imagine if louise
was
35 or 40 or 45 now
and the message she would have on
youtube or instagram and the ability to
have obviously she built a huge company
massively successful but the impact that
that
i think a lot of people don't know who
she is she's kind of like just before
everything started to pop
um similar with like before everything
started to pop for our generation she
was pretty popped for her generation
right
or sure but like all the videos of her
are there's not that much video content
and it's right it's older louise hey
which is still great but still not tons
and i don't think that she started her
career until she was in her 50s i
believe
yeah so that's why she's you know older
in most of these videos
what would she say now
yeah well just i
i think she would say a lot of the same
things such as the impact that she could
have like she
she would be doing a daily youtube show
or daily ig live series a daily podcast
and just
how much more impact you know like she
would be a household name because of
not just the message but the heart and
soul and care
that she has i mean that's why books are
amazing because books that can carry
your legacy forever
you know i can i will pass whenever i
pass knowing that i've left behind
currently right now nine books and
hopefully i'll have many more before i
before i die but i know that when i
leave here i will leave a lot behind me
and that's why a book i think is so
profound and a video you know and what
we're doing here and you know all of it
it's going to be holograms and in vr and
100
that's right we'll get there um
okay talking about service so a lot of
the stuff in your book is obviously
healing self and there was a lot of new
terms for me to get used to you know
re-parenting yourself and um protectors
and on the concept of being more
compassionate towards yourself and so i
guess if you're not familiar with those
concepts it takes a little bit longer to
get through the book although it's a
it's a very short you know it's a very
short
pac read here um but service is what i
was curious about uh we're in this text
group with some amazing friends people
done amazing things in the past 48 hours
has been a lot of gabby hit the new york
times let's go and cheering you on and
your response at 6 39 this morning was
thanks guys so proud the book is serving
so many souls and if you look at your
youtube and you look at your instagram
the theme of service
just flows through everything that it's
not just about you that you're you're
trying to give and support and care for
people and it's real it's not just pain
lip service because it's a cool word but
it's like actually at the core of who
you are
so how much does service tie into the
healing process for you or prescriptive
for others as well
well
i think that
we all have the capacity to be of
service to others but the first thing we
have to put first is a service to
ourselves
because my ability my capacity to not
care about the list and care about the
service more way more and just see that
you know acknowledgement as a reflection
of the service
is because of the profound devotional
attention i've given to the service of
my own self my own soul
my own
reclaiming
the fragmented parts of myself and
bringing them back to safety
and as a result of that
transformational journey that i've been
on for 42 years but really also you know
since i really got sober when i was 25
i i've been on this devotional journey
of serving my spirit and my system my
internal system and in the service of
myself i've been able to now sit here in
the seat of self-energy of of compassion
of courage of calmness of connectedness
and in that seat i can just have one
focus and one focus only every single
day how can you use me that's my prayer
i wake up in the morning and i say what
miracles would you have me perform today
how can you use me and to be a humble
servant of god of an energy beyond my
own and to be a conduit through which
that messaging and that energy comes
through very very naturally because we
are in a very very big crisis right now
in the world and it is horrific and it's
terrifying and it's it's heartbreaking
and everyone's traumatized and you can't
be alive and not be traumatized right
now and i just see so clearly how my
soul made the choice to come into this
lifetime at the time that i did to make
the commitment to have the discomfort
that i had so that i could overcome that
discomfort so that i could be here right
now 42 years old sitting grounded in the
seat of my own
strength and recovery freedom and inner
peace so that i can show the
for everyone that i touch in whatever
way i can do you fully heal from the
trauma
you know it's funny you ask that
question because i was on the today show
last week and
hoda asked me the same question she said
can you fully relieve yourself from this
trauma from trauma and i said to her
there's absolutely no way i would put my
face on the cover of this book with the
subtitle the guided path from trauma to
profound freedom and inner peace if i
wasn't living in profound freedom and
inner peace
and now evan that doesn't mean that i
don't go to therapy every single
wednesday at 4 45 if you're looking for
me at 4 45 on a wednesday you have to
know where i am
but it does mean that i am now seated
confidently in my own grace because of
the commitment to my inner work and
there's no way i could have published
this book
without being in that grounded state
because if i if i wasn't there i would
have reactivated myself while i was
writing it and i would be reactivating
my readers but because i wrote this book
in that steadiness the reader can
co-regulate with my energy that's inside
that book
you know as you're talking what's
flowing through me is that i think of aa
and the sponsor system where
once you've come through it you sponsor
somebody else to help them on their
journeys a little bit sooner and that
also helps you from going back down
because you're you're serving people
does the does the service now for you
with i mean you don't have to write
another book if you don't want to i mean
you're called to it
does does the service part there
keep you
at the fully healed level like if you
weren't serving and helping others do
you think it you would slip back
no way i write my books for myself first
okay i do this work for myself first
the
benefit of being able to do this kind of
work is that you can then
re live to tell
and so as much as i am in the commitment
in the service of others it all starts
with me so there's a couple of times now
we've kind of led to sequence here right
so when i talked about surveys said yes
or others but you have to serve yourself
first
um
in the book there was also a great line
talking about medication so you've been
open to say that hey medication saved
your life and if you need the medicaid
you should do it because it gets you to
a certain point right so page
120 everybody medication can help get
you to a safe baseline where you can be
calm enough to do the deeper work
which also kind of at least leads my
formula brain to think sequence like
step one is get to a certain level and
then step two is you can go deeper and
maybe step three is service
is that well i want to acknowledge that
quote in context to the message because
i think that we live in a country and a
society and you're in a different
country but we live in you know a
society in the us in particular where
we're often overly medicated but that
stigma and then there's a very big
wellness stigma around medication that
stigma actually kept me from getting the
support that i needed when i was living
through postpartum depression and
anxiety and insomnia and suicidal
ideation and i lived in that state for
four months if not a little bit longer
and it was only until i hit a massive
bottom that i finally accepted my
diagnosis and got on a medicated path
but the message in that chapter is so
profound which is that the solutions can
come to you in many different forms and
i love to reference that that that that
story of uh
the man who's drowning and he is sent a
boat and he's like no i don't need a
boat i'm gonna you know god's gonna help
me and then he sent a helicopter no i
don't need the helicopter god's gonna
help me and he sent a raft i don't need
that raft god's gonna help me and then
he drowns and he ends up in heaven and
he's like god where were you
and god's like i sent you a boat man you
know i sent you a helicopter and so for
me i just was running from the
helicopter in the boat by not taking
seriously the diagnosis that i was
living with and getting on the medicated
path and in my case that medication was
the boat the helicopter the raft and it
got me back to a baseline of safety and
in that baseline of safety i didn't just
numb out i went
diving deep into three therapy sessions
a week
and transforming the inner workings of
my brain my neural pathways my nervous
system and my beliefs about myself every
step of our internal journey once we
make the commitment to pick up a book
like this or still listen to this kind
of episode on your show we have this
desire to heal we have a desire to be
free and so when we make that decision
we're going to be sent a lot of boats
and helicopters and we're going to be
given a lot of guidance and it's our
responsibility to be
uh
brave enough to say yes to the wisdom
and the guidance we receive
you've talked about
gently guiding people forward which
which
really the first time i i kind of heard
you say it resonated because i think a
lot of the content at least in in
youtube land
i don't want to call it masculine energy
or alpha male energy or
if you have a problem suck it up stop
complaining stop whining get off the
couch and go chase down your dreams you
know it's like a lot of that kind of i
don't know what label we would attach to
it but there's a lot of that hey if
you've got a problem
that's just an excuse you got to go and
get to work where your approach is
very different and amazing and and
the the whole concept of gently guiding
people
forward
what does that mean to you
well i think that you all people are
suffering
and
one of the sort of push past get it done
move through it
is another protector it's another form
of protecting us from feeling our
suffering because it's like the further
i the more i push
the less i have to feel
so the
path that i perceive to be the real
healing path is to reverse that
stop pushing and start allowing
start noticing start feeling
and that's a slow and steady process
that cannot be
forced it cannot be
pushed fat pushed past it has to happen
slowly and gently because
trauma is very delicate and we all have
it and it's if you if like i said
earlier if you rip off the band-aid too
fast
you'll get blown out
it'll be too too scary at once
so the modalities that i speak about in
this book like somatic experiencing and
emdr and internal family systems therapy
eft
are all very gentle practices that
slowly titrate in and out and in and out
and you don't have to just dive in head
first but to trust that those subtle
moments even this most subtle moment in
a therapy session or when reading the
practice from this book
where you just start to feel slighter
sense and sensation in and then a little
bit out that's a miracle moment
so we have to add up those miracles
let's check in on
the actors who would play you in a movie
anything
about i was thinking about claire danes
claire danes wow okay
i like that we could we we need to
manifest claire danes playing gabby
burns not i'm not 100 sold on that but
there's a depth
and a vulnerability
that
she has as an actress that i don't see
often
and that would be absolutely necessary
to play the role of gabby
i like it
maybe along those lines if you
think back to any kind of historic
situation or character
where you could help them this is
obviously um
i think what you're kind of doing is
you're pulling all these different
modalities that maybe have been around
for a while but from different cultures
you know i mean you're talking about
breathing techniques that come from
different cultures the the japanese
techniques the the the voot or i don't
know how the chanting um theme that
you've got in the bucket i was trying to
do it out loud i wasn't sure if i was
getting a writer
[Laughter]
tapping like all of these modalities
that have existed for a long time but
you're kind of putting them all together
in one book
uh if you could go back to in in
some point in time to maybe a historical
figure who you knew was suffering from
trauma and help them is there anybody
that comes to mind you'd love to have a
conversation with them to not just to
learn as a mentee but to actually help
them through what they're dealing with
to be a support system for them yeah and
like a time of crisis gandhi huh
well one would want to stand beside and
know what that what that kind of
selflessness
was how what the resonance of that was
because that kind of energy needs to be
cultivated more right now
and if i could right now in this moment
just hold someone and be there as a
president as a steady presence of
security
it would be for zilinski
to just be a presence for him
in particular right now and i think that
we can be that presence for him and for
what we're witnessing
for all those souls in the ukraine
because we we have
to really never underestimate the power
of our presence and the power of our
energy and the power of our prayer so
for people who are looking at the news
and they're seeing all these devastating
things
and they feel hopeless but they want to
help but they don't know how even that
concept of saying a prayer or being
present what what could we do if
somebody's watching this video what
could they do right now to help just
with their presence
well first and foremost
recognize that your true power lies in
your presence and the presence that you
show up with is either polluting the
energy of the world or it's elevating it
what we have to do is start to take
ownership of what we put out because
what we put out has a ripple effect with
our child our child goes to school and
brings that to other children our
husband our husband goes to work and
brings that there our wife and she
brings it to her work and whatever it is
it's just a ripple effect and so we have
to be a presence of steadiness and
security and safety and compassion and
love for
all of those individuals that are in our
close proximity because they spread that
and also
never underestimate the power of our
energy because when the collective is in
crisis the biggest gift we can give when
we feel powerless is to collection is
the collection of
calm compassionate courageous energy
and so that that energy has resonance
and that energy also logically does
things for us it says okay wakes up in
the morning and says okay go donate here
okay go direct message that person and
help them seek refuge in your
country it just puts you in action but
it puts you in an inspired action not
fear-based action
because fear-based action is going to
not be good for others or for you
so we have to really begin to settle our
systems so that we can show up with that
presence right now more than ever
last question for the people who
want to thank you for all the service
you've been putting out and the
positivity of the vibes if they were to
pray for you
tonight people watching this video
what would you have them pray for
oh bro evan what a beautiful question
it's like so it's so moving to me
i would have them just pray for me to
to be safe and
secure so i can continue to do what i do
i love it
the woman is gabby bernstein the book is
happy days we will link it up in the
description below go check it out and
support this amazing woman thank you
gabby appreciate you you're an amazing
interviewer i've never really maybe
we've done something a long time ago but
you're excellent at interviewing i just
want to acknowledge you for that it's
beautiful
trust my dream
yeah man
yeah you don't need to be anxious before
your interviews you've got the secret
sauce dude you got it man okay thank my
protectors i gotta acknowledge and thank
my protectors yeah yeah no but you're
you're very very very good at it and
you're doing such beautiful work thank
you evan cool thank you gabby
bye baby if you want to see the
one-on-one i did with mel robbins check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there i hate you evan i
hope you lose evan i hope your business
goes bankrupt evan evan you're a
terrible person i spent the first
40 some years of my life trying to be
somebody else